on this project any features
I got baby Grizzly on there shout out to
your brother that's it that's it no
features I love it
I Love It I Don't Need No features
though yeah because it's like
I don't know I don't want no features
unless it makes sense yeah that's fair I
would like to get Alicia Keys
awesome [ __ ]
it's not that's pretty I think that's
realistic yeah
you know I always wonder when you have a
song like first day out
and now everyone makes a first day out
when they get out of jail everybody's
got a first day out if you've done jail
time you get out and you drop a song
called first day out yeah yeah yeah it's
pretty crazy
um but your song is one of those songs
that
forever will get played in the club
no matter what club you go to
it's like Dreams and Nightmares is gonna
play first day out is going to play it
is like one of those iconic records that
it's just it's just a staple
um what's it like having one of those
you ever get tired of the song like you
know what I'm saying come on man I thank
God for that that's a blessing bro
change your life yeah change my life
it's a blessing it's a blessing to have
that for sure yeah you know what I'm
saying I feel good yeah cause it's like
I feel like at least in the last 10
years
I don't know like songs that are I mean
because now we're going on five years
that song's been out it's been five
years it's been it's been six years
it'll be six years in November yeah
there's not a lot of songs that are six
years old still getting played peak
hours in the club right now and like
when you go it's not like they're
playing it just because you're there
it's like no they're gonna play anyway I
don't remember what songs came out
around that same time really the only
other song um is Dreams and Nightmares
that came out in 2012 though I know but
I mean that's like that old or and then
obviously like depending on where you're
at little whistle you know Juvenile Back
That Ass Up You know but on some like if
you're like I'm talking about peak hour
[ __ ] yeah yeah fast yeah for sure yeah
shout out to uh yeah shout out to that
recommend it's definitely a classic